hey youtubers it's Charlie so in my Game
of Thrones video last night I asked you
all to submit questions so I picked 10
to answer in this video with one bonus
question also since there were a lot of
plots that they didn't deal with that
we're gonna have to talk about in the
finale I tried to make most of the
questions about that kind of stuff real
quick Congrats to Manuel's sake you're
this week's giveaway winner you win a
$20 Amazon gift card I'll be reaching
out to you on your channel for details
but my next round of the giveaway will
start whenever I post my finale video
but since it's the finale I'll just be
doing devil I'll be giving away two gift
cards and then after that's done I'll
just move the giveaway to another video
like Doctor Who or something else but
I'll still be doing a weekly giveaway so
before we get to questions there were a
couple really cool things that I saw in
the comments that you guys pointed out
so feel free to shout out if you were
one of the people they commented one of
these cool facts first off
tormund Giantsbane is going to be
replacing the Val character from the
books as the person they keep is a
prisoner at the Nights Watch
number two Pip and Grenn were not killed
in the book but they were killed on the
show I saw a lot of you were more sad to
see them go then you were to see Ygritte
die which I thought was really funny
number three the battle between Jon Snow
and the thin at the end was an homage to
Donal Doyle he was a Night's Watch
character from the books that they cut
out of the show
he was the blacksmith which is why Jon
rolls over to the Forge and then kills
that then with the blacksmith's hammer
in the books he was the one that went
into the tunnel to stop the giant from
coming into Castle black and shout-out
to Japanese zombies who suggested that
the girl Maester Aemon was talking about
might have been one of his sisters
either array or addala just because it
would have been a Targaryen tradition to
marry your sister I don't have any way
to fact-check it but it's the best
suggestion I saw in the comments so big
shout out so time to answer some
questions careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet but
here we go
question number one kami asks do you
think Brienne will fight the Hound based
on the way that they edited the teaser
for episode 10 I think they want us to
think that if you look at this first
picture it's brilliant unsheathing
Oathkeeper then it cuts to RA in the
Hound approaching someone off camera
that looks like they're wearing
Brienne's armor it would be a big
departure from the books but it'd be a
way for them to kind of bring things
full circle and tie up some of those
loose plots for those characters I don't
want to say what happened to any of
those characters in the books just
because it might turn into spoilers but
where things are right now with
the hound and Brienne and Podrick are
really different from what originally
happened the show changes little things
but largely keeps it the same as the
book so for instance Ygritte died in the
books she died on the show she just died
a slightly different way in the books
question number two Nicole asks what
happened to ghost so he's just hanging
out recovering from the battle he's not
dead or anything they don't put the
wolves in every scene just because they
have to add CG to regular-sized wolves
and it's super expensive
the dragons are really eating most of
the cg budget this season and they're a
big part of the finale so expect a
really crazy dragon scene next week it
also looked like ghosts did not go with
John - manses camp so we probably won't
see ghosts next week but there haven't
been any new dire wolves to die on the
show since Nigeria off and gray wind and
lady were killed question number three
fatima asks why did John go to Mance's
camp without a weapon I actually saw a
lot of you guys asking this question so
there were actually a couple reasons one
because mance still thinks that John is
on his side and two because he didn't
want to lose Longclaw if he was killed
right now man still thinks he's part of
that raiding party it's a bit of a plot
hole because the Raiders used a war to
learn their defenses so why wouldn't
mance also use a war to do the same
thing and see Jon Snow wearing the black
and the reason he didn't want to lose
Longclaw is because he made a promise to
never lose it again so obviously if he
died they would have just taken it and
it would have been lost forever Jon did
say that he's gonna go and try and kill
him but I think that they're gonna end
up sticking to the book plot I won't say
what that is just because spoilers and
if you have read the books please use
the spoiler tag when you're commenting
about it on - question for Steve asks do
you think the title of the finale being
the children for shadows the children of
the forest so yes but I also think it
means a couple other things I think
we're gonna meet one of the children of
the forest via branch group it looks
like they reach that weirwood that he's
been singing his dreams I also think the
title refers to Daenerys as children the
dragons and the stark children in
general there's this one shot from the
season 4 trailer before the season
started the first trailer that we
haven't seen in any of the episodes yet
and it's Daenerys beneath that pyramid
and marine I won't say what that scene
is just because I think it's kind of
spoilery but as it relates to Brienne
think about her mission to find the
stark children it looks like she
probably going to run into Aria in the
Hound she's thinking in her head she's
supposed to return lady Catelyn stilled
Rijn to safety but just in general I
think the children of the forest is
gonna be the biggest tease I think
they're just gonna tease them and then
they'll become a bigger part of season
five and question number five Jose asks
can Giants be turned into White Walkers
so their corpses can be reanimated into
whites just like any other corpse but in
order to make a giant white Walker
they'd have to turn a baby giant there's
a rumor inside the Canon of the books
that brand the Builder used magic to
enslave Giants to help him build the
wall so Giants are susceptible to magic
so White Walkers probably could turn a
baby giant if they found one question
number six Daniel asks would Sam become
the new maester if Jon Snow became the
new Lord Commander so it wouldn't
necessarily have anything to do with
John becoming the Lord Commander but
typically the Lord Commander would just
appoint a new maester that would really
only happen after a master a man died
and we did not see him die during the
battle John would probably pick Sam to
be the new maester but Janos Slynt and
Alliser thorne I don't know about them
they would play end up picking into just
because all the other brothers would be
vastly under qualified if Sam really
wanted to be maester though he'd have to
go and study at the Citadel and earn his
master's chained otherwise he couldn't
call himself a maester he would just be
performing the duties of a maester but
would not be an actual maester question
number seven Sara asks which characters
do you think get the best treatment from
the writers this season so you're asking
about which characters do I think that
the show is pushing the hardest like
pushing forward is the most important
Peter Dinklage for sure I saw a chart
after season two that compared to the
screen time everyone got and there was
definitely a small group of people that
got way more compared to season one
Peter Dinklage has always gotten the
most even if you think about Daenerys is
the most important character but just in
general the characters that have gotten
the biggest push this season have been
Tyrion Jaime Cersei as well as Jon Snow
and Daenerys after them the rest of the
Lannisters and the Starks get way less
screen time and then after that group of
people the secondary characters almost
got nothing just in terms of fan
favorites
I think the Tyrion is gonna walk away
again this season being the biggest
badass question number 8 EO and asks do
you think they'll still finish the
season on something to do with
ice yeah I definitely think that they're
gonna end with something on Brandt's
character I think that's what they're
gonna pick just because it typically
alternates between Daenerys and
something in the north question number
nine Laurie asks was the wall built to
keep out White Walkers or wildlings and
didn't the Giants help build it so the
wall was built to keep out the lands of
always winter to seal that off from the
rest of Westeros that's where the White
Walkers were treated to at the end of
the long winter yes Giants helped build
it and the free folk to everyone that
lived in the North helped built the wall
you have to remember that the wall is
about a thousand years old so it
predates the Andals invasion in the
formation of the Seven Kingdoms after
they invaded relations with the first
men who survived the invasion
deteriorated and anyone not wishing to
bow to one of the new Kings just moved
north of the wall they became what you
would call the wildlings but they're
really called free folk so it's been so
many centuries since the wall was built
everyone has just forgotten that it's
not there to keep wildlings out it's
there to keep White Walkers in I did a
whole other video about the long night
and the building of the wall that goes
into a much greater detail so I'll have
a link to that in the description
question number 10 Alex asks which new
characters do you think will show up in
season 5 so mostly Martel's and Doran
characters I also think there's gonna be
some new characters in Braavos and
marine I don't want to go too crazy with
spoilers so you can watch the season 5
video I did a couple weeks ago if you
want to learn more I also included
another link to that in the description
too so I've been doing a lot of bonus
videos this season so there's a lot of
fun stuff going on so one last bonus
question
mini frost giant asks if you were a
character on the show which God would
you worship so if I got to choose which
kind of character I would be I would
probably either be someone from house
Tyrell or House Lannister just because
I'd be rich in my quality of life would
be so much better if I got to choose who
to worship without my house making fun
of me too much
I probably worship the old gods when you
talk about the old gods and the White
Walkers you also have to talk about the
children of the forest because they were
instrumental in helping defeat them
during the original battle during the
long winter so I would probably put my
faith in them if they beat the White
Walkers once they can do it again
and you'd have a much easier time
convincing the children to help you if
you practice the same customs and
religion so I'm really just trying to
increase my
odds of survival but if I got a second
choice I would pick roller the right God
because if I died at least he'd be able
to bring me back so thank you so much
for so many questions these are always a
ton of fun to do like I said my next
bonus video will apply be ranking all
the previous finales I'll try to post
that on Thursday and I'll do one more
bonus video before the finale and then
probably like three bonus videos next
week and then it'll just trickle off to
like one bonus video every Sunday right
now click here to get my episode 9 video
and click here to learn about some of my
favorite prophecies on the show thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow high fives